after spending time in South America
trying to shore up support Ukraine's
president will head to the US for
meetings at the White House and capital
on Tuesday meetings with the president
and Senate leadership Vladimir zalinski
has faced before but this will be his
first sitdown with representative Mike
Johnson as speaker and like his
predecessor he has a group of ultra
conservatives in his party that are
opposed to more funding for Ukraine and
if Johnson attempts to bring legislation
to the floor he could face a rebellion
though talk of his ouer has not surfaced
yet President Biden is pushing for some
$60 billion do to assist Ukraine further
but Republicans say without new money
for increased security measures at the
southern border funding for Ukraine
simply can't go forward experts argue
Wars are not overnight events and
political bickering could send a signal
to Russia that cracks and the Western
Alliance are forming the White House has
for weeks been warning that lawmakers
need to come together we're running out
of money and and we are nearly out of
time any member of Congress who does not
support funding for Ukraine is voting
for an outcome that will make it easier
for Putin to Prevail with each visit to
the US zalinski finds fewer politicians
lining up behind him and fewer members
of the public with polls showing that
support is starting to wne now if Aid
can't be sorted out during this meeting
and before lawmakers leave for the
holidays the president may be forced to
Aid his allies at the expense of the US
Military
by redirecting resources Reggie Chini
Global News Washington